how you know people this is the Rubin
report and according to the paperwork I
am Dave Rubin and I have to to time
repeat Rubin report guests say that five
times fast
Vanessa Barnett Lisette Padilla with me
and in case you haven't noticed there
has been a lot of news in the news
lately it has just been an endless news
avalanche
mostly horrible stuff but we're gonna
get to some fun stuff too but let's
start with with Ferguson Missouri which
of course you guys all know about at
this point we haven't covered it on the
show yet
so I wanted to just sort of do a general
overview of what's been going on of
course eighteen year old Mike Brown was
shot by police officer Darren Wilson
about ten days ago
looks like six gunshots facing the
officer so he was not running away
actually facing the officer we've just
got a little breakdown of the timeline
so let's take a look at that okay so on
August 9th Michael Brown 18 robbed a
convenience store and was shot to death
by a police officer Darren Wilson he was
unarmed but reportedly reached for the
officer's gun that seems to be up for
debate at the moment on August 10th the
candlelight vigil was held to honor
Brown which turned violent more than a
dozen businesses were vandalized and
looted more than 30 people were arrested
and two police officers suffered
injuries tensions rose between
protesters and police every night and a
little bit more forea on August 16th the
state of emergency was issued for the
Ferguson area and a curfew was imposed
from midnight to 5:00 a.m. the curfew
was lifted after it failed to thwart any
violence on August 18th
so the curfew has not been in effect for
the last couple days this has become a
huge media circus on top of the
obviously awful situation in the first
place we've got a couple images of the
militarization of the police which this
seems to be beyond the the death this
seems to be the part that has everybody
up in arms so to speak so these are
these are just we got four images for
you I mean this really looks like and
you guys can chime in of course this
looks more like a military than a police
doesn't it
and I think this this photo and
subsequent photos I kind of spoke to why
people thought that tensions were
growing because a large number of the
protests like 90 percent of the protests
were very peaceful yeah but then some of
these peaceful people were met with guns
in their face and then that kind of just
it's a snowball effect and so you
shooting this to me is the iconic one a
guy on what appears to be a tank
basically was the McDonald's in the
McDonald's in the background that
McDonald's actually got into the whole
story because that's where the reporters
got arrested immediately but I mean
literally with a sniper rifle aiming at
people are also going from military
operations that are being passed over to
police departments because of budget
cuts and so you are seeing sort of an
increased militarized militarization of
police officers because of the nature of
the weapons that are available to them
yeah okay so I want to get to the
militarization stuff after but let's
just start with what actually happened
and from everything I've been watching I
find it very hard to ascertain what the
actual truth is I don't know that we're
ever going to get to the truth you know
now they're saying that the officer has
had a broken eye socket because Mike
might have punched him how much do you
think we're ever gonna get to the truth
let's just start there I don't think
we'll get to the truth because the two
people involved one is no longer here
and one has been shrouded in secrecy
like he hasn't spoken up he's delivered
messages to friends who have been
delivered messages but it's gonna it's
gonna be one-sided the story will always
be one-sided and like you said you have
a broken eye socket but then there's
another report that he wasn't in the
hospital but for an hour or so and so
you just have conflicting reports that
everywhere you turn and that's another
reason why everyone's so angry because
in the very beginning there was no
transparency we they had no the people
of Ferguson had no information you know
his body was on the street for four
hours uncovered like these little things
that keep coming out it's just angering
this town and so it's creating this
divisive Ness it's now a race issue it's
just so much for this small city it's
it's overwhelming so speaking of lack of
transparency that to me also is the
bigger part now we've got all the media
there but for the first couple days
there seem to be like a
you black out there was a no-fly zone
because somebody said they somebody shot
at a helicopter how much of this really
is just like a media circus at this
point beyond again the facts that we're
trying to get you yeah I think the lack
of transparency is one of the biggest
issues are not the main issue because
unfortunately these incidents where we
have the youth being shot by police
officers happen time and time again but
this particular case in the way that it
was handled I think has brought so much
controversy and brought all the riots
right they didn't even want to release
the officer's name we didn't even know
as Darren Wilson for a long time that
officer's policing the area now with no
name tags which I don't even know how
that could possibly be legal and we we
still don't have it we barely got
information about the autopsy too right
we don't know if these shots were fired
at close range or you know long range
and that's really gonna impact the way
we view this case as well you know if we
find out that you know these shots were
fired long range then there's really no
case for this struggle that happened
supposedly between Darren Wilson and
Mike Brown right but we still don't have
that information and I think that's the
issue that we're getting a lag and all
the information and so much of it is
being hidden yeah now Vanessa according
to my paper here it says you are
african-american okay so then obviously
you represent all african-american
people because that's what they do on my
shoulders yes it's a heavy burden so as
the representative your community how
much for the black community in America
right now how much of this goes beyond
this particular incident and more tongue
the bigger issue of race relations and
you know everyone said we're post-racial
with Obama and all that kind of stuff
and that that phrase right there just
angers the group anymore but it does go
much further than just Mike Brown we've
had cases you know Trayvon Martin is
still a very sensitive topic you know
Oscar Grant you know from vacillation
you know there's just so many there was
just another african-american shot in
st. Louis yesterday exactly and so we
we're in a period where we want to be
united as a nation and we want to be all
as one and we want to look at this as
America's problem things that we all
need to solve but when you get to the
root of it it was a white officer and it
was an unarmed black man and so
that tension is still there and it's a
difficult dialogue but it's one that
needs to be discussed so that there is
healing that we can move forward and we
can't all come together because not
every white man hates a black man you
know it's not that and we can all sit
together and be diverse and have these
conversations and not have tension in
those conversations yeah what do you
make about the people on the right that
always say well look what's going on in
Chicago because they always bring up
Chicago probably since we started this
10 people or Chicago I mean it's it's
almost that bad but they say well we
keep ignoring Chicago but then we focus
on this what do you what do you think
that um you know I think that that's a
tough question but I think like I
mentioned earlier we have cases
happening in Chicago in Illinois we have
them all over the country so I don't
think it's a Chicago issue I don't think
it's a you know Ferguson issue it's a
national issue so for me that's almost
like a distraction tactic they're saying
who but what about Chicago that's right
you're Cosmo until something happens
somewhere else and then suddenly they
start caring
all right final thought on this so just
the the media angle of it is there an
inherent problem with the media that the
media constantly because they need
people to watch they have to keep
ratcheting it up tension all the time so
you can already see how the media gets
involved in the story Chris Hayes on
MSNBC they spent half the day talking
about how someone threw a rock at him
someone get throw a rock at him and then
they spent the day talking about it you
know apparently someone Don Lemon heard
someone say the N word so then the story
becomes about what Don Lemon heard like
how much is this just that the media
just keeps this thing going and yes we
need to shed light on it of course and
we're talking about it right now so I
say that with all you know the great
assault but you know but it's one day
it's one thing to tell the full scope of
the story and there's another thing when
you are trying to create or manipulate
the narrative and that's what happens a
lot of times you know instead of
focusing on the case and what the facts
are and what we're learning they're
focusing on the riots and the Molotov
cocktails and looping four scenes over
and over again to make it look like that
is what's all the only thing that's
happening in Ferguson and we need to
really look at the fact that there are
being there are three autopsies that are
happening and the first one we heard are
just planetary preliminary reports and
so we argued
some information and if we would just
focus on the information we're getting
and what we still need to get then we
won't get shrouded in distraction
tactics as we have been yeah media how
do you decide who to trust when it comes
to this guy's I think it's really
difficult to decide who to trust but I
think this makes an excellent case for
having police officers wear body cameras
and having some more video footage
eyewitness testimony is awful we know it
doesn't work we have different accounts
here here's a perfect case for
advocating for body cameras there you go
all right so obviously that that's just
a little wrap-up of what's been going on
there hope we gave you a little insight
into it and of course this story is not
going anywhere
speaking of stories that aren't going
anywhere Isis we've been doing this
every week and we had another beheading
video that we could have shown you this
week but I know we've done two pretty
graphic ones over the last two weeks and
unfortunately these are not gonna stop
either so Isis just yesterday released a
video of the beheading of James Wright
Foley who is an American photo
journalist who's been missing in Syria
for about 22 months we're not gonna show
the video here because it's been taken
down from YouTube actually Twitter
already has issued a thing that they're
suspending accounts that put up images
of it I had to delete my tweet about it
we're gonna show you one screen capture
from the video just real quick okay so
you just so you know just throwing this
up so you know this is real what we're
talking about and everyone this has
already been confirmed by by our State
Department and all that so basically
Isis is running rampant through Iraq
through Syria it seems to me that we
don't know what to do about it and you
know flags are being raised in European
capitals in England and in France etc
etc I want to get to what the Pope had
to say about this but what are we
supposed to what do we make of this Isis
we've never seen anything like this
we terrifying I think this is one of the
the first times that Isis directly is
sort of warning the US and saying we're
coming after you yeah and here's what
we're gonna do we know this is one of
your people a journalist which should
you know really journalists should be
protected they they're there to report
information they're you know supposed to
be unbiased source of information we
really need journalists so to put them
in danger is absolutely tragic I'm
pretty sure Isis doesn't operate
standard the thing that's really scary
too is that they say that they have yet
another American journalist and they're
threatening to do the same if we do not
stop our intervention and what blows my
mind to is that here we're intervening
in Iraq because we have a minority
population that is being decimated so
we're sort of entering the situation it
seems like on the outset or just at
first blush not for politically
motivated reasons this is an economic
condition this is because a Christian
minority is being persecuted so we're
there to help and this is what these are
the consequences it's absolutely tragic
so we've been talking about that a lot
so there were these 40,000 Yazidis that
were trapped on this mountain Isis was
surrounding them we had some airstrikes
it sounds like we helped some people but
now apparently they're still being raped
and killed and all that kind of stuff
what what are we supposed to do here
because it seems to me we created the
problem with the first war that we
shouldn't have gone into then Obama got
everybody out not that it not that we
should have stayed but maybe we left so
quickly that there was a power about
like it's just a big freakin mess but
what what do we do now well I hate to
trivialize it but we're damned if we do
and if we don't
and the more we try to help the worse it
gets
and you know I know we're gonna talk
about the cool Pope who says you know
maybe forces need it now and for so long
it's you know we've stuck to our guns
and we do not negotiate with terrorists
and we don't do this we do exactly but
what we're doing what it's not working
and we're losing our people and that
shouldn't be what we're faced with when
we're trying to intervene and help a
situation so I think that force is
needed at this point and it needs to be
in a different capacity than what we've
been trying yeah all right so before we
get to the to the Pope for all the
people that say you know we shouldn't go
back in and we shouldn't do anything
what would you say to them because it
sounds like both you were kinda at least
for air strike
or something and that's I know the
YouTube commenters always got what you
Americans are screws everything up
either way well what would you say to
them we have to get our people like you
can't leave them there we can't have
another beheading we can't just oh
you're going to pull out now whatever
happens to the rest of our people that
are there and the rest of the people
that are being hurt we don't care
anymore it just it logically that
doesn't make sense yeah I think it's
very sort of complex moral territory
here there are many philosophical
implications you know Vanessa you
mentioned we have to get our people but
do we not have a responsibility as one
of the largest super powers in the world
to also protect innocent people and
children these children are being
murdered you know they're being starved
to death and and yell at you and say
well you're an interventionist and let
everybody else do it why doesn't the UN
do it but I think it's been proven that
pretty much unless the US does something
nobody does anything unfortunately which
is why we're damned if we do yeah and
you know there are some reports that say
that the US airstrikes were critical in
taking back the mussel dam and having
having the Cordish people and take
control of it you know if if Isis would
have taken control they could have
potentially starved the entire popular
with a huge portion of the population or
they could have used it to essentially
you know flood a bunch of cities they
could have done so much damage and so I
think there we saw sort of a situation
where we absolutely had to intervene
yeah but it's it's a really tough
question do I want my you know soldiers
my my people my resources my you know
our country's money to be devoted here
no absolutely not I'd rather this
situation not be here but I think in
some ways we have to consider the
possibility that we are partially
responsible for the situation in the
first place and we should act
accordingly yeah I think we're all
pretty much on the same page there and
then the Pope chimed in and we've got
the quote the Pope said in these cases
where there is an unjust aggression by
Isis I can only say that it is licit to
stop the unjust aggressor i underscore
the verbs stop I'm not saying bomb or
make war just stop and that means that
can be used to stop them must be
evaluated so obviously the Pope doesn't
want to come out and be like
bomb these [ __ ] that's not how
folks operate but he pretty much is
calling for military action there right
like that's pretty much he can't say it
outright but I think he's pretty much
saying you know prayer doesn't work
really like isn't that you know they had
the prayer thing for Gaza and Israel a
month ago but when it really comes down
to it we can all sit and pray that the
Yazidis are not going to be slaughtered
or that they're gonna release this other
journalist that they have but that
probably won't do anything but feel free
to take the other counterpoint well I
think in in his mind I won't speak for
the Pope but I saw much people who does
pray very often and I believe that in
your prayer things are revealed to you
so I think in his prayer maybe it was
revealed to him that you know these are
the actions that may need to take place
in order for the peace to be restored or
in order for the outcome that is desired
you know to happen happens and so I
don't think he's saying whoo I'm done
with this prayer thing you know it ain't
working let's bomb him but I think he's
saying you know I have my faith I have
my beliefs but at the end of the day we
still need physical action here on earth
I can pray to my Heavenly Father but we
still need physical action here on earth
to go in and stop these forces I don't
yeah I definitely agree with you in that
Nino he's not saying that we should stop
pray or anything like that he doesn't
even mention I'm but he is saying just
stop right and he emphasized it that
emphasizes that he means not war not
bomb like he is very clear that he's not
calling for military intervention he's
just saying we need to figure out a way
to make this right or is he just isn't
that just placating like I can't go and
call for war so I'm gonna say just stop
that doesn't really mean it what does
that mean really just stop like you
could stop but Isis isn't gonna stop and
I don't think they're taking advice from
the Pope are they like they don't really
care coaches right zena's are
persecuting a Christian minority I know
yeah I think I I think what he wants to
say in saying stop is that I don't have
the answers is what he's saying but
in an ideal world if we're looking at a
utopian society yes let's make it stop
and he can say that and he can still be
the Pope and he can you know still talk
about prayer but he is still looking at
this situation and trying to put his own
input into it I guess I can't like I
thank you for the pony fare and bomb
some good but just stop like that sounds
really nice like just stop all right so
my final thought on this so the the
censoring issue because you know when
Twitter censored these videos yesterday
and I had to delete my tweet about it
and they were suspending accounts not
just telling people have to take them
down they were actually suspending
accounts you know everyone kept saying
well we're just giving them propaganda
and I completely disagree to me it's
like we have to show this stuff so that
we understand what we're fighting here
or at least what's going on in this
other part of the world where do you
guys fall out on that that we should
that that were just propagating it if we
if we retweet it or that we should just
not be showing it out of either the
respect to the dead or it's more so
about what the viewer takes from it I
think it's a video that I haven't
watched myself because I can't you know
how much I cry I cannot watch that video
but I think the video needs to be talked
about it needs to be spread and people
need to know this is what is happening
yeah and like nowadays if you don't take
a picture with Beyonce and put it on
Instagram no one believes you saw
Beyonce so if you don't see this video
people will not believe that this is
actually what we're facing and so it's a
bit of a hypocrisy for Twitter to
suspend these accounts and be enraged
when people can say whatever they want
and threaten your life and they can
still have an account right and so it's
a little bit of a gray area but don't
spread the video so you can hashtag it
in get followers like that's demeaning
but this is information and you are a
news source so yes it needs to be a
discussion I don't agree with you
Vanessa so I think we need to have
access to this information needs to be
available to us and perhaps it's our
responsibility to educate the public and
people who have access this information
so that it's not made a mockery today so
that we understand it unfortunately you
know as you mentioned Dave when we have
this type of information and it spreads
and through social media forms and it
goes viral
then it unfortunately sometimes fuels
the terrorist organizations
you know motives and desire to do this
even that's what they're saying yeah so
it can potentially perpetuate the
situation but I would say we can we
should err on the side of having more
information versus having information
taken away from us and being blinded to
what's happening we can't act if we
don't know what's happening is a perfect
ending to a segment all right let's move
on did you know that the Republicans
don't like President Obama and that
President Obama doesn't really like the
Republicans yeah I guess you probably
knew that that's not news but the New
York Times had an interesting piece that
came out yesterday about how the
Democrats actually the congressional
Democrats especially are actually
frustrated with President Obama as well
the article was titled Obama is seen as
frustrating by his own party and we're
gonna get to a quote from it but a lot
of it had to do with the conversation
that Harry Reid who's a Democrat
obviously was having with Mitch
McConnell a Republican about Iraq and
Harry Reid went to the president and
sort of wanted help and basically Obama
just brushed him aside and said you deal
with it Harry and the article basically
goes to how Obama kinda seems distant
even with his own allies in his own
party so let's look at a quote from the
article in one sense mr. Obama's
response was a reminder of what made him
such an appealing figure in the first
place his almost innate aversion to the
partisan squabbles that have left
Americans so jaded and disgruntled with
their political system but nearly six
years into his term with his popularity
at the lowest of his presidency mr.
Obama appears remarkably distant from
his own party on Capitol Hill with his
long neglect of would be allies catching
up to him and it goes on in interviews
nearly two dozen Democratic lawmakers
and senior congressional aides suggested
that mr. Obama's approach has left him
with few loyalists to effectively manage
the issues erupting abroad and at home
and could imperil his efforts to leave a
legacy in his final stretch in office so
I think there's a lot of interesting
stuff here you know he was getting a lot
of [ __ ] this week because he's been on
vacation all week while all this obvious
Isis stuff is happening and Ferguson he
did go back to DC to issue a statement
you know people are always attacking
presidents for taking vacations I mean
they gotta be
human too but this one does seem
particularly odd to me at least so what
should we make of the Democrats is this
just like lame-duck guy you're six years
in six and a half years in we know
you're almost out and I kind of think
he's kind of over it yeah yeah maybe
he's also a little overwhelmed and
overwhelmed right um and so he's kind of
saying I really don't want to get
involved in Capitol Hill politics then
kind of over it like I'm dealing with
guys in Iraq that you know my bama's I
don't know what the guys thinking right
um so he was reportedly quoted as saying
you and Mitch work it out so maybe he's
kind of saying like hey guys I trust you
you're adults start acting like it maybe
he's the one that's frustrated with how
ineffective Congress says well I think
he is and I think that's what they're
saying they're like he wants I think to
me it seems like he's a professor and he
wants the government to operate the way
that it's supposed to by the books you
know maybe like Congress supposed to
work some stuff out and then get him
legislation and these things simply
don't happen which is why he has to take
the executive action and that kind of
stuff but that doesn't make him a good
politician and I think that's where his
fault has been like just believing well
Harry you got to work it out with him
cuz you guys are in Congress like
sometimes the president is supposed to
be involved me that's what they said
Bill Clinton was a great person cuz he
was involved in all of the legislative
stuff well first I know I don't think he
ever set out to be an ideal politician I
think again that was a part of his
appeal he didn't want to fit that mold
that we've seen so many times before and
secondly I know I've seen bosses a
million times saying look I hired you
for the job how about you do it and so
you see my plate is over foot like
overflowing with things that are going
on I feel like this is an issue that
maybe if you start working on maybe I
can come around the back end and meet
you like I feel like he was just kind of
giving them the power to resolve this
issue and as far as the vacation he
doesn't strike me as a man who goes on
vacation and turns off his phone it's
like the world's gonna keep turning I'm
gonna go surfing like I don't think
that's what he does I think he's still
very in touch with his team I think he's
still very abreast of the issues and I
think he's still working even when he's
away and I feel like everything he does
is strategic yes I'm an Obama fan I'm
shirkers rise but I'm not just saying
this because you know everything he does
is right there are things that he could
do better but I don't think he's just
like Oh check the deuces I'm almost out
I just don't think that's where his
frame of mind is well first time I think
we over it and overwhelmed for the title
for his book when he you know when he's
out like that's a great title they ask
you something like really serious but
over and over whelmed my time is the
president I think that's a great idea do
you think he liked campaigning more
that's kind of also what I think about
him again I think he's a pretty decent
guy and I think he's doing the best he
can the Republicans suck I get it like
the whole system is broken but he really
really liked campaigning and getting out
there with the people I don't know that
he really likes the the minutiae of it
so that's why oh how are you deal with
it like I get it like Harry that's
supposed to be your job but I think of
another person Bill Clinton for example
I think would be in there every day like
trying to get things done again the
Republicans suck I know I'm gonna be up
to was incredibly likable and he was
great at relationship so I think that's
not Obama's forte he's been heavily
criticized for a TV me know mansion a
centrist Democrat says my relationship
with the president is non-existent
really and I think that's a case from
many in Congress whether the Republican
or a Democrat and and sure you can argue
that this is potentially poor strategy
on his behalf but guys he got reelected
he's not trying to be reelected again he
doesn't need to be popular now and he's
had some pretty successful executive
orders also so he's kind of like oh you
guys need me for something or you don't
want to pass something I'm just gonna
sign it into law so right maybe any
stories on that or we could do plenty
more come out throwing about that either
do you think partly though like at the
end of the day the expectations were
just too high like when you come in on
hope and change
like you know you mean like it's like
we're six years in now the hope and
change like doesn't seem like it really
worked like we have Obamacare we have
universal health care it's great but a
lot of the other stuff like our standing
in the world doesn't seem better it
actually seems worse like was it just
too much to have a guy come in with like
an idea
more than a policy you know I don't
think hope so much failed I think hope
actually worked feels like I don't we
got hope it's not in my notes here okay
I think I think a large part of the
country actually had hope going in
believe that yeah yes the hope work the
change okay you know I don't think as
many of the changes as like first of all
there's just too many people that want
too many different things so everyone's
not going to get what they want and then
that's me dumbing it way down me being
bottom of the barrel here everyone's not
going to get exactly what they want and
the problem with that is they think they
should but people in Ferguson are saying
Obama come here and take care of it what
our when he lands what do they think
he's gonna do right it just doesn't work
like that and I don't think people
understand what his presidency entails
and unfortunately a word like change is
going to make people actually think you
can deliver all of the changes they want
and you can't just don't think you can
yeah bring us home no and you mentioned
that you know people might think that a
word like change means we're gonna get
changed and I think that's actually the
problem that we had very high
expectations as you mentioned and we
were incredibly naive we thought that
because we had a Republican president
before now we're gonna have a Democratic
president that was gonna do completely
in the office that you know the other
guy [ __ ] it up so badly that this guy
is gonna make it right
politicians are politicians they're
bought out if there's a lot of money in
politics Democrats Republicans are more
alike than they are dissimilar and I
think that's what we need to start
focusing on not who's Republican not
who's Democrat not what campaign
marketing strategy they're using to
convince us to vote for these guys in
the end there are a lot of special
interest at play here i co-signed all
that okay do you know that the cost of
raising a child is completely and
utterly bonkers we do have a mother on
the panel so we're gonna find out
firsthand CNN calculated the average
cost of raising a child to the eighth
age of 18 throughout the country so
let's take a look okay so what you're
seeing here that on the bottom you see
in the years of age and a one-year-old
the costs about looks around thirteen
thousand bucks and that's got around
there for the first seven or eight years
and then around ten it starts jumping
and then it gets precipitously higher so
that by eighteen you've spent around two
hundred and forty five thousand dollars
this includes childcare and education
health care food housing etc etc let's
look at the Northeast so this is where
it's the most expensive and it's almost
double I mean that's crazy if you're in
the Northeast it is almost double and
this is for high-income families now
let's look at the the rural graph let's
see where it's cheap although this
doesn't seem that cheap to me over the
course of 18 years rural families are
spending around one hundred forty five
thousand dollars to raise children by
the way the country's median income
remains more than eight percent below
where it was before the recession but
child care health care costs are still
going up faster than inflation so all of
this just sort of adds to a lot of
badness economy not great costs going up
by the way we do plenty of stories here
about how college education no longer
gets you the jobs that it is I should
point out that this does not include
college this is for the 18 years of life
so we're not even factoring college cost
here yeah I had a baby in 2013 what was
I did I not check these faxes get mailed
to me did no one put this in a class
that's not a you don't get like a packet
they don't give you a pamphlet and
rightly so because people wouldn't have
children reading that they just say no
lock it up I don't want it I think those
figures are probably low I think I spent
two hundred forty five thousand I was
just last week in swimming class and
gymnastics and they don't even account
for like the extras that you have to do
just to keep your child in the same race
you know they have the you know Spanish
class French class now you need you know
Mandarin I could drop the French a much
French
I know it's just overwhelming to think
that it's only going to increase
it doesn't include college where are
people supposed to get this money and
you brought up the rural area being you
know one hundred and forty five thousand
dollars will they make a lot less yeah
so it feels like four hundred thousand
dollars to them and so you just don't
know what you're gonna do but we've been
doing it for years
you know these children still get raids
they still grow up they still go well
some of them still go to college and
somehow someway parents make it happen
you cut costs where you can so is that
the overriding theme on this thing like
when I see these studies it's like you
know what people just this is what life
is like you just keep moving forward the
next generation keeps coming and yet
maybe it gets more expensive and more
difficult but like it just kind of keeps
rolling along sure you can argue that I
would say that it keeps getting worse
for some people and it stays the same or
gets better for others and that's that's
a small minority um you know but Vanessa
to your point you talk about these you
know extracurricular activities this
like summer school and things like that
and I think because we see such a huge
cost to having a child those families
who have more money are going to be able
to provide those resources like summer
cap to their children and this is
increasing the education gap and that's
one of my serious concerns when I look
at data like this I know that you know
the kids in upper middle class you know
upper family upper class families are
going to get that instruction in the
three months they have off whereas other
children might not right so how much of
this then is just keeping up with the
Joneses like that you have to give your
kid French and Spanish and how about
something useful or Spanish to do school
well you know to me like you got like if
everyone else take you swimming classes
you got to take the swimming classes and
gymnastics and all that I don't think
that's so much it's the part of keeping
up with the Joneses but you know if I
buy a Greco high chair that's only like
70 bucks and someone goes and buys this
new fancy Stoker yeah two hundred and
fifty dollars back that's where the
disconnect is and that's when you're
trying to keep up with the Joneses I
think it's healthy to put a child into
different activities to kind of flush
out what their interest is interests are
I did the same thing I did and you can
do free activities too what big this
yeah but you do
out of things and by the time you're in
high school you realize what your
passion is you focus on one thing and it
doesn't cost as much money and so I
don't think so much of it is keeping up
with a jobs it depends on your family
and we don't believe in living outside
of our means so if my I can't afford it
we don't buy it it's very simple for us
you bring up an interesting point with
the like high chairs or like all this I
don't even know what kind of highs but
you know I think a lot of times parents
are placed in a position where they feel
like they have to buy that other chair
because it's safer because that's the
thing that the good parent would do so
it places an unburdened stress on on
these families that don't have the means
to perhaps purchase that chair but
they're gonna put it on their credit
card because that's what a good parent
does and they don't want their kid to
fall and have a concussion so fear has a
lot to do but at one thing that doesn't
cost any money is research you can
research what the differences are you
can research what tests were done you
can research to see if in fact one is
safer than the other but you have the
education to understand how to think
critically the Ameri information
available to you and if you have the
time if you're not working two jobs then
yes I would argue you can you can do
that if you have internet in your home
but if you don't have these resources
available you're at it right so it's
such a huge double-edged sword because
we don't fund education properly then
these people feel like they have to send
their kids to private schools so then
already they're now putting more money
into that system we're putting less
money into the public education system
but let's talk about these Stoker's my
brother got one for his kid stroller but
you can't but they never use it because
you get so Smita Milus that you can't
like hang [ __ ] on it which I guess
parents have a lot of [ __ ] spaceship
almost don't know how to work it now I
will say that I have this still good
carrier but I didn't pay for it for free
and it's like a contraption that I
cannot figure out like you strap the
baby and the baby's like on your back
your neck your head you're flipping it
around it's it's more than you need he's
not gonna be happy about this
I have a website that you know I
dedicated solely to mommies and babies
and figuring all this out and you know
I'm not play cating to any brand you
know sometimes the cheaper brands aren't
crap they're [ __ ] sometimes and
sometimes the more expensive brands are
that for a reason but you don't need a
spaceship stroller you really don't
because you can get a number of stroller
and I know I'm going way too far with
this but you can get a cheap shoulders
that strolls your baby and is not gonna
knock it out and give it a concussion
there you go people you don't need a
spaceship stroller what's your what's
your website by the way I went on your
website the other day is awesome at
layout is very cool yeah some motherly
things there are so few people voting in
LA that there are now people talking
about paying people to vote and giving
them prizes to vote LA Times had an
interesting piece on this let's look at
a quote maybe it's $25,000 maybe it's
$50,000 that's where the pilot program
comes in to figure out what number and
amount of prizes would actually get
people to the voting box that's Nathan
Hockman the Los Angeles Ethics
Commission president so yeah voting has
been going precipitously down in Los
Angeles our current mayor in Los Angeles
Eric our city got 12% of the eligible
voters actually voted for him that means
12% of the people walking around in LA
actually voted for the guy that's
running the show let's look at some
numbers on how the voting is falling off
so in 1969 in the mayoral campaign
76 percent of the eligible voters voted
that's pretty decent for a democracy I
wish we could get that in our in our
presidential voting then in a March 2009
primary for mayor 17.9% voted and then
June 2013 we had a mayoral run off which
is what Eric Garcetti won twenty three
point three percent of the eligible
voters vote deport he got around 51% or
something so 12 percent of the people in
LA voted for this guy so voting is a
major problem
I have long said the boding election day
should be a national holiday every year
people have to go to work get let's
remove that from the equation let's get
people voting I think that would be one
simple way of fixing this
but paying people and prizes this is
just a big game show now is America just
a big old game show what's that
fortunate that we need you know a game
show to incentivises to vote but it's
somewhat understandable Dave I think
that we're so disillusioned with the
system that we don't think our vote
matters it kind of doesn't right we know
that when we have corporations that can
have can give unlimited donations to
political candidates are you know vote
it's gonna be pretty insignificant now
in terms of giving people money you know
I find it absolutely ridiculous but I
think it's some out-of-the-box thinking
and it you know I might get some people
out to the voting polls now who's gonna
go to the voting polls right that's
that's a question that I would ask if
you're offering say twenty five thousand
dollars some people might think oh I
could really use that money I'm gonna go
and vote whereas others might think
twenty five thousand dollars is not
gonna make a difference but yet others
who are educated on the statistics are
gonna do the math and be like it's not
really gonna much right so it literally
would be like it would be like lottery
they're not just handing out twenty five
grand to go vote like I think you would
have a very specific portion of the
population showing up to the polls and
that might actually influence the way we
would the way we vote and also the
results of the election so that I think
would be interesting and then it could
just backfire you can have so many
people show up that the lines are longer
and now people don't want to wait until
more people leave like this could just
be a [ __ ] show you know how sad is the
state of democracy in general like when
you see these things about the voting
you know to me like we're all in the
political world the news world like we
talk about this stuff all the time
obviously a set the money and politics
thing is big for all the stuff that we
do around here but how just sad is just
the generals like people just don't vote
they just don't believe it works they
just they don't believe so it's not
about money it's like about belief yeah
and it's like even if you do vote even
if you if the person you voted for gets
into office you still feel like you're
not gonna get the result you want so why
even bother but it is particularly sad
especially as a black woman because you
know it wasn't that long ago when we
couldn't vote and so a lot of times and
you know we had to fight so hard to get
the right to vote so it's very upsetting
to know that it's trivialized and it's
just that privilege it's just like I
don't care anymore people literally died
for us to be able to vote and to know
that people aren't going to the polls
because they don't feel like it it's
it's I can't even believe it yeah how
much of this is education though because
I feel like when there's a presidential
election you know we always get it the
uptick in numbers so we get something
like 60% or I think Obama's first
go-around it was really good like 70
percent don't quote me on that exactly
but then in the off years it's
ridiculous I mean we literally are
getting like 20% and something like that
fer so this year we're in an off year
2014's an off year so we're gonna be
able to vote for Congress and the vote
the turnouts gonna be terrible despite
the fact that they have like a 7 percent
approval rating so this is really just
about education right it's education and
it's it's almost the exposure like a lot
of people at the I know don't even
realizes voting day yeah and so when
it's the presidency there's a commercial
every five seconds but a lot of times
you don't get the information which is
the education you don't understand who
your options are you don't understand
all of the proposals that you're voting
on and people aren't taking the time to
do the research and really read through
all of the rigmarole because it comes
out to the fact that they just don't
think it matters
yeah so for the money are going well the
money in politics thing do they just
have a vested interest in not having
people vote and that's really what's
going on here interested not having
certain people though they're trying to
make sure that the the people that are
gonna vote in their favor vote and those
who don't don't and this is why when you
mention education I don't necessarily
think it's all about education I think
the biggest contributing factor here is
awareness particularly through media as
you alluded to Vanessa right so when we
get commercials and propaganda I think
that's what really moves a needle when
we instill fear that if we don't vote
for a particular candidate that other
candidate will leave us jobless and
we'll lose our homes like this type of a
misinformation is I think what really
pushes people to vote so education that
definitely has the partner but when
people are really educated I would argue
if some say forget the system I'm not
part of it I'm leaving the US or Y vote
if it doesn't matter
well said I'm pretty sure if you just
gave out
ps4s people would start voting massive
record numbers alright we got one more
for you we haven't done anything on weed
lately most of our stories have been
good about weed it's slowly getting
legalized especially medicinally people
are understanding that it's not going to
kill you and in many ways can help you
especially if you're sick but now
lip-balm weed is the newest trend in
weed but don't take my word for it let's
look at Fox affiliate on the marijuana
wax
it's a marijuana product that is
catching on with teenagers and Sarah's
got the details I want to look out for
okay I had never heard of this it's done
by I know until very recently it goes by
the name wax butter and honeycomb on the
streets and it can pack a kick equal to
15 to 20 joints of marijuana let me show
you what I'm talking about here this is
a picture of the product from our sister
station W AGA in Atlanta wax looks and
feels like lip balm it's made from the
oils of marijuana plants and has a high
level of THC that's a chemical that
produces a high police say while it is
easy to make the ingredients needed to
make it are flammable which could lead
to burns or even cause a house to
explode local news really like the way
their cadence that which they speak at
all times and it might blow up your eyes
it's just terrible cable news all right
but I do think the weed wax is kind of
an interesting thing so we've got some
more info on it wax is also called BH o
which stands for butane hash oil or
butane honey oil the weed is placed into
a long tube or pipe which is then hit
with a rush of highly flammable butane
more than 80% pure THC that's the stuff
that gets you high it's gonna get you
higher faster
it's rumored to be the most powerful
form of marijuana on the market and a
wax can be extremely hallucinogenic so
that's good for the mushroom people and
one more video for eeeh this is this is
someone smoking the wax
[Music]
[Laughter]
that is that is Roscoe rapper Roscoe
Roscoe - that is Roscoe - one of my
favorite rappers why why would you want
to be that high I think is the first
question I literally can take one puff
of a joint now and I'm good to go for
three hours and it's obviously for my
severe back pain coma but like really
I'm good to go like so I I do think
there's something nice about this wack
stuff which we'll get to but why would
anyone want to be am i just old now is
that all cuz I guess I did that in
college you know it comes down to
efficiency yeah we as a people have less
time we don't have time to roll 15
joints right and smoke them all so
getting stoned for a year right yeah
that's like a mirrors where the Stone
Age into one efficiency I don't even
smoke I'm liking the minority I don't
smoke at all but I get the thinking I
honestly get the understanding that you
just want to get it done as quick as
possible so you can get to the other
things you have to do yeah what's that
you love the efficiency eighty percent
THC right this and that did not look fun
I don't know if you get I mean a Roscoe
didn't look like he was enjoying himself
he was carving he was on the floor I
mean if you smoked a joint all by
yourself and you're not that used to
think you know the THC you end up
feeling awful you can get paranoia you
might end up falling asleep you start
hallucinating right when you have
something this powerful I'm afraid that
people might actually start acting like
they do when they're like on mushrooms
or Mathison like that like what can be
the potential effects I don't know
in terms of the hallucinations they both
start with him really they're nothing
alike but when it's this powerful you're
really looking into right a substance
that's no longer really an herbed like I
think the whole appeal of marijuana is
that it's this natural thing that you
find in the earth that's grain and you
smoke it and it's like happy and no
chemicals here you're using butane and a
lot of times this butane can contaminate
the wax and you're gonna be inhaling
that [ __ ] like it's awful for you like
let's keep it green that's what it's all
about let's keep it green she's never
smoked weed you're obviously on the
marijuana Council of America so right so
I do think that's part of it that when
you smoke weed there is this sense like
this is something natural and whatever
and the fact that you need that butane
that amount of heat no one's sitting
down and saying you know the THC levels
and this are so high and you need the
special tours no boys would like yo I
got the best [ __ ] on earth so you're
gonna be high for days like fish it is
crazy he's like yo let me get it but
there's no education there's not like a
sit down let's talk about this let's
talk about the effects yeah he doesn't
care so even though you're even though
you personally don't smoke weed you're
for the for staying out of people's
business like look if you need it
especially for medicinal issues yeah
then by all means do is you have to do
yeah I don't get in your business don't
get mind you don't know what I'm doing
my house I'm just really for people
being able to get the things that they
need to make them feel better and if
that's it then by all means for me this
whole waxing is really just a dick
measuring contest like oh yeah you can
smoke two joints I'm gonna smoke all
this wax you know oh my gosh and they're
really just trying to prove that they're
like macho and like a brother like what
I can do it's it's kind of ridiculous to
me yeah so do the pro weed people behind
the wax thing like I get it's like a
cool idea or whatever like I get that
part but are they actually harming the
legalization effort because then people
see those videos and yeah then they're
gonna say oh my gosh you know you know
my neighbor's house burned down because
of marijuana
marijuana's burnin down houses that's
the dialogue that we're gonna start
hearing that's gonna be the narrative
and that's incredibly harmful I'm I
don't know I think that there are better
ways to smoke weed and get that THC that
this form seems highly dangerous I think
oh my god there I just feel misled like
I really thought it was gonna be a lip
balm
yeah that's all well I feel like if it's
really like a lip balm like almost like
an edible if you just put it on here
like hi and it's not you're not falling
over like rice broth that's sort of
where I thought it was going you're
marketable absolutely they're missing
the big picture here they buried the
lede for someone that doesn't smoke weed
you've got a lot of good ideas on how
people should ingest we on that note I
want to thank Vanessa and Lissette their
twitters
are right down below and puff puff pass
people you don't need that hard [ __ ] all
right we'll see you next week
[Music]